pretty good day monday for the
washington football team chris
beating the pittsburgh steelers are you
okay previously undefeated pittsburgh
i'm fine i just paused for effect and to
make sure that
to make sure that i'm not drowning in
what i drank right before the show
started but
washington
not only won the game
but came back
from down 14-0 the 38th time this year a
team has come from 10 or more points
behind to win an nfl game that is a
record through 13 weeks with one week 13
games still to play
impressive resilient yeah gritty
tough
i don't want
to criticize the steelers as much as i
want to praise
the
washington football team
for doing what no one thought they would
be able to do and it would be very easy
to just fold the tents down 14 nothing
and it just hey it's not our day
but they kept coming they kept coming
and the steelers didn't take advantage
of opportunities to to put the dagger in
and and you leave the door open
long enough and the team's going to come
back and get you and that's what
washington did so kudos to them look we
like the chase of perfection
it's sad when it ends because it
enhances the season a little bit right
but it's also it's also kind of neat for
a team like washington trying to stay
alive in the nfc east to get it done and
there's larry sanchez i love it having a
cigar and some form of hard liquor he
said i'm a washington fan tonight and
yes he is they can pop the champagne
they can smoke the cigar they can drink
the bourbon and they can celebrate that
their 17-0 undefeated record
is preserved for at least another year
chris yeah no i mean it's always a
that's a tradition i always look forward
to seeing larry zanka and a few of those
72 dolphins guys kind of celebrate that
last team losing their game and whatever
else but um
you know let's start with pittsburgh
right i mean just because they're the
undefeated champions of the pft power
rankings and everything like that out
there
yes washington deserves a lot of credit
we'll hit on that in a minute but
i mean we've seen pittsburgh the last
two games they're flirting with danger
right and i think we saw finally kind of
everything kind of come to a head and
some of their good luck or good fortunes
ran out we've seen them fort with danger
early on in the year and a lot of these
type of football games but what we're
seeing as the game season goes on teams
that have certain matchups against them
and we're starting to see some of their
flaws and hey
the defense last night kind of got worn
out as the game went on no bud dupree no
pass rush that was a little concerning
as we went through there and then
offensively and of course the no run
game and having depend on the short pass
game constantly constantly and the
receivers dropping those passes when
you're gonna play that style of football
well if you don't execute that style of
football consistently then you know what
it's the nfl and you're gonna be in a
close football game and uh washington
hung around and give them a lot of
credit for playing tough but pittsburgh
blew many many opportunities for the
second week in a row it's just this one
they lost
i think being undefeated this late into
the season also creates a significant
amount of stress on everyone involved
and and the coach is the embodiment of
of what's going on in the locker room
and we saw and heard from mike tomlin
after wednesday night's win over the
ravens 19 to 14 a game that should have
been 19-7 late touchdown made it seem
closer than it was from a score
standpoint but they were sloppy they
were sluggish they were not impressive
and tomlin blew a gasket it was the best
coaching rant of the year he was upset
he was determined
and he was ready to hold his guys
accountable
so
when they lost last night
i told the other writers at pft i'll
take the tomlin press conference i
assumed it was going to be another
epic moment
let's hear a little bit
and see a little bit of what tomlin had
to say after the steelers finally lost
the game
points along the journey you get a
chance to learn about yourself who you
are what you're made of individually and
collectively and it takes the journey to
reveal that and so you know um we're
faced with a loss now so we'll get an
opportunity to smile in the face of it
he seemed relieved i watched the full
four minute post game press conference
he seemed relieved he was upbeat it was
a 180 for what we saw on wednesday i
think that he at some level
is happy that they finally got this loss
out of the way i think he knows this
team isn't good enough to go 19-0
they're going to lose at some point and
with each passing week it was more and
more and more pressure exactly if you're
going to lose one lose to the nfc team
because they still have the tiebreaker
over the chiefs i mean if you had to
pick one of the last five games to lose
that's the one to lose because if
everything else is equal you're still
the one c now it's not going to be easy
to beat the bills and the colts and the
browns
but if you're going to lose to any of
those teams washington's wanted to lose
to because they still steelers are
technically the one seed in the afc even
though they're tied in the record with
the kansas city chiefs yeah well i i
mean you're right it is it's the right
team to lose lose to as far as that's
concerned and i think with mike tomlin
first off he's just got a great feel of
you know when to when to beat your
players down and be tough right it's
almost like vince lombardi that way like
after a tough loss he loved him after a
good win hey that was a time to you know
okay kind of let we got to fix these
areas and do that i think he's got
compassion one that you know guys in
that locker room are disappointing the
undefeated run is done so he's trying to
do that but also i i to your point i'm
sure there is some relief he realizes
that yes going 19-0 is very tough to do
and the one thing again a loss will do
to a coaching staff now you can really
sell to your players hey we got to
change this or we have to do this and
have to get better at it you know when
you're winning every game players want
to say hey hey what we're doing is this
is good why would we mess with this as
everything's good you know the coaches
feel that same way too now in the light
of loss you sit there in that spotlight
and you start to reevaluate and go wait
can we really throw it 51 times five
yards down the field every game
to go through the afc playoffs and win
the super bowl and do all of those type
of things so i think it's a chance for
their where they get to go back and
reevaluate and now they can sell to
their team some of the things they need
to fix too and obviously there's there's
a few things that need to be fixed with
this 11-1 football team
james connor is earning his second
contract via his absence he's missed two
games after testing positive for coven
19. we hope he's doing well he's a
cancer survivor which puts him at
enhanced risk of a negative outcome of
covet but the running game without james
connor is abysmal last night the starter
in place of james connor benny snell had
five yards on eight carries that's a
jerome bettis stat line minus the three
touchdowns
anthony mcfarland the rookie had four
carries for 15 yards jalen samuels
whatever happened to him one rush for
one yard and that's it embarrassing 53
passes for 305 yards and uh
the the uh look you're right it's it's
basically
pass it pass it pass it not far down the
field
and and you can't you can't do that
consistently because you're
one-dimensional that way and you become
a hell of a lot easier to defend well
exactly i mean you know what you see is
okay you drop a few passes and you know
people i know are on the pittsburgh
steelers wide receivers the last two
weeks listen when you throw the ball 51
times and you got 50 51 darts being
thrown at your head at four yards away
and then hey there's all these big bad
dudes in the middle of the field trying
to rip your head off i mean hey you're
gonna drop some passes you know again i
know there's a little more than we'd
like to see but i think it's a little
bit of the you know repercussions of the
way they play too i mean how many
receptions do we see the pittsburgh
steelers catch and just boom boom boom
and get crushed as soon as they catch
the ball right so that's part of the
game but you're right mike i mean they
have to have or infuse some run game to
their football team because what we've
seen here now the last two weeks with
defenses that can whether just match up
with their wide receivers with pure man
power right like the ravens with marcus
peters or marlon humphrey or whether
it's a team like washington who has this
great front four and now they can use
the scheme behind it and zone coverages
and all that
either way if you can make the wide
receivers and the pittsburgh games
struggle or take them away to a degree
we're seeing there's no other answer to
the offense and i think that's
concerning and it's just hard to think
that you're going to go to the super
bowl without playing a team somewhere
here down the line especially in the afc
playoffs that will be able to match up
to that passing game a little bit again
and give you issues and then and then
what and i think that's why they have to
readjust their offensive style here a
little bit
and when that's all you're doing it
develops a rhythm that becomes easier
for the defense to adapt to like you're
saying short pass you know it's going to
be there you you you can get even more
of a head of steam because you're in
that cadence you're right look at the
lines like chase young running all over
the place last night
yeah easier to knock balls down
because it's this every play it's the
same it's the same it's the same you get
you get the timing down and eventually
you're smacking the ball all over the
place and that was the dagger when the
steelers were down three and trying to
go down and force overtime or win the
game a batted ball picked off and that's
that so it wasn't sustainable i think
that's why tomlin was so upset last week
he knew they were living on borrowed
time it was just a matter of time before
they lost and now like you said they
have the ammunition where in the film
room on the practice field
they can try to implement some changes i
don't know what they can do yeah like i
said they need james connor back badly
and uh they need to maybe think about
son and do a contract i know they don't
like to do business during the season
but uh you know they're going to get
themselves into another libyan bell
situation after the season if they don't
they may have to let conor hit the open
market because they're surely not going
to use the franchise tag but but they've
got to address that position because the
guys who aren't named james connor just
aren't getting it done and that's a
problem for this team you can't be the
pittsburgh steelers and not have a
running yet no you can't and they've
they've lost attitude that way you know
the offensive line you could see it it's
not even a good run blocking all o line
at this point because it's just been so
past heavy that of course yeah there is
no attitude there's no thought of or
just consistency of driving off the ball
and and having that you know camaraderie
and being all on the same page as far as
five offensive alignment in the run game
it's too few and far between to get in a
rhythm that way just like anything
whether it's writing an article talking
here in the microphone shooting baskets
throwing a ball you got to get in some
little rhythm and to go oh short pass
short pass short pass short pass hey run
the ball you know the offensive line
they're at a disadvantage that way
they've been on their heels pass
protecting for the last eight plays in a
row so now to think that they're going
to come off the ball and dominate and
overpower a defensive lineman in the run
game that that's just not realistic that
way and here's the other thing that
jumps out to me mike as you watch the
game i mean obviously they need a run
game
but
uh
big ben calls every play at the line of
scrimmage
he's gonna have to run the ball too
you know i i don't i wonder as i sit
there and watch the game
was that a run play should he have ran
the ball there um that looked like he
had the he could have ran the ball there
and he threw to it like hey if they
blitz this guy throw it here or if the
guy's off coverage throw there so i
think big ben is part of this solution
too to where he can't be so past happy
when he's back there orchestrating the
offense as well
let me just say this and this is with
all due respect to ben roethlisberger
he's had a hall of fame career he
deserves to get into canton with his two
super bowl wins
it was the super bowl loss though that
created so much chatter about
an effort that was maybe too aggressive
to try to showcase him and make him the
mvp of the super bowl because he wasn't
the mvp of either of the two super bowls
he won and chris i can't help but wonder
if what you're saying is accurate and i
have no reason to doubt it that he's
possibly changing plays at the line of
scrimmage runs into passes
we've had this
narrative that pops up from time to time
all year long why isn't ben
roethlisberger one of the mvp candidates
why is it why why you know and and
could it could it be
as he had why isn't he the comeback
player of the year why is it alex you
know i i there's always been that
attitude that ben doesn't get the
respect he deserves and he's the guy who
is ultimately the one who's not getting
the respect
you got me curious now on whether or not
i just he's choosing to throw the ball
to try to maybe get himself in the
conversation with russell wilson patrick
mahomes and aaron rodgers i you know i
don't know and i'm i'm not but but you
know knowing knowing him that offense
you know what you're seeing and listen
just my experience as a quarterback
there he's doing so much at the line of
scrimmage every play
uh yeah i feel like there was a handful
of plays last night that one i thought
were hey you should have gave the ball
to benny snell but you threw the ball
you had a little bit of a rpo option and
hey listen you know as i always say if
you get the quarterback too many rpos
he's gonna throw the ball he's always
gonna justify to the coach oh hey i had
chase claypool one-on-one or hey i had
juju smith schuster one-on-one he'll
always justify that so that's that
that's sometimes where you gotta take it
out of his hands and i just have a hard
time believing
you know as mike tomlin as much as he
loves big ben and knows how awesome he
is that he would want to sit there and
have offensive coordinator randy finch
go and hey let's let's throw it 52 times
today let's do that with our defense and
everything like that that just doesn't i
don't know maybe i'm wrong it just
doesn't look that way and it doesn't
make sense to me
knowing mike tomlin as a person either
and i just i i feel like yes the run
game gets overridden a little bit
because big ben is just going to check
to a pass
when you have a quarterback with a big
personality you have to have people on
the coaching staff who know how to deal
with him yeah right in the right
direction and i really do believe at
some level there's an element of this
what about me what about me why i'm
always hearing about my homes and rogers
you know i've got two super bowl wins i
you know look at my career stats why
aren't they talking about my career
stats why aren't they talking about this
why aren't they talking about that it's
human nature i think at some level to
feel that way yep and it's human nature
at some level to act on it and again i i
the only reason that i
that i even
begin to thread that that string of
popcorn is super bowl 45
i've heard time and again that
one of the problems was
bruce arians who was the offensive
coordinator at the time hey and ben
rothersberger trying to showcase ben for
the mvp and look they ultimately retired
aryans because he was
this is as the theory goes he was too
close to roethlisberger and it was
counterproductive because they were they
were joined you can't you have to have
that that symbiosis that relationship
that that can reign in a quarterback who
maybe wants
to to go out there and be the gunslinger
and overdo it and throw the ball 53
times right on a december late afternoon
early evening when you need to establish
the run before you try to throw the ball
yeah i i mean listen again we don't know
but
you know it just it's circumstantial
evidence it's circumstances substantial
answer
and it's it's it's you know i'm a guy
again just ex
my experience and just what i'm seeing
is kind of
i'm thinking that again we don't know we
don't know either way now the other side
of this too mike is i mean the defense
they did have a 14 point lead against a
team and a quarterback who i thought
would be like the last team in
quarterback i mean you know i call him
charlie check down at times and he was
driving me crazy early on in the
football game with lack of
aggressiveness but there you go alex
smith once again it just shows you he
doesn't lose your football games he'll
let you hang around and he waited for
the right moment to kind of put his foot
on the pedal and made a few plays but
hey the steelers defense too it's two
weeks in a row here where
you know hey we're supposed to dominate
this team just shut them out and of
course they let them hang around and
slowly but surely they hang around and
it gets really dangerous in the football
game
and alex smith once again determine
showing his toughness and determination
with the images that emerged you know if
you were trying to time it out just
right so you would eat dinner at
halftime
of the game you may have changed your
plans after what we saw with
the the blood streaming down the shoe
making kurt schilling's bloody sock look
like a paper cut frankly
and then you could see and it's very
good that they wear burgundy
socks or whatever that that those tights
are that kept
kept it from being as graphic as it was
but there were there was a moment where
it reminded me of jed klampet shooting
the ground and up came some bubbling
crude i mean the blood was just kind of
gushing from the leg and smith said so
after the game they just wrap it up and
he keeps going i mean this guy's
incredible and and i guess after you
deal with what you dealt with with the
right leg this this really is nothing
just wrap it up and let's go we can put
stitches in it later but the guy's
incredibly tough yep the guy's
determined and and he's they should just
give him the comeback player of the year
award now there's no way he's not going
to win it there's no way if anybody out
there and we have ways of getting the
names of the voters and who they vote
for if anybody votes
for
anyone other than alex smith you will be
shamed you will be doxxed you will be
called out repeatedly
and and you are being yes we are
bullying you
into voting for alex smith because there
is no way you can make a case to vote
for anyone but alex smith yeah well i i
agreed i mean 100
everything he's gone through uh it's
remarkable
my little boy last night was calling me
out he's like oh alex smith is playing
oh alex smith is playing dead you said
he was done why is he out there i was
like he goes he's not even done
you know before the year because he was
asking me and i was like oh philip you
know i think he's done you know so he's
calling me out you said he was done what
happened well okay i had to tell him the
story but it's it's it's amazing because
i did think he's done i i thought that i
i didn't think there was any way he
could come back and play effectively and
do that but as you see he moves he's
tough like you said takes care of the
football knows how to manage a football
game that's where he's at his best and
he realized his defense was hanging in
there and he didn't take any chances to
ruin that and then there they go
they they wore down pittsburgh i mean
pittsburgh's d died out a little bit you
know i think two things that jumped out
to me about pittsburgh z last night one
no bud dupree right i mean the pass rush
was good but it wasn't like dominant
good and especially not in the key parts
of the football game where you'd like to
see them you know take over and make
life hard on a guy like alex smith
and then the other thing you see too
because we haven't seen pittsburgh have
to play a whole lot of these teams
listen i'm still going to question
pittsburgh coverage-wise i am you know
and when they need to play man-to-man
can they play man-to-man in pittsburgh i
don't know you know i love their zone
blitz blitz package and all that stuff
yes but if that pressure doesn't get
there there's a lot of holes in that
zone blitz package and i think that's
just something to watch out for and
they've haven't really had to play that
high octane we can throw the ball
against man or zone and that type of
quarterback all year long they've been
fortunate not to have to deal with that
uh but that that showed to me a little
bit of a problem with them last night as
well
let's hear from ron rivera coach of the
washington football team on where last
night's victory
ranks it's it's up there i mean you know
and again
you know in spite of some of the
decisions i made today you know they
they they played their asses off you
know then
this really does rank up there just
because the fact you know who we beat we
beat him in pittsburgh you know the
pittsburgh steelers that you know that
that's one of the story franchises as
well in this league is
so to come in and win you know that was
big for our guys real proud of them
signature victory of the season by far
for the washington football team and
they're now tied with the giants at five
and seven
for the first place position in the nfc
east the problem is they've been swept
by the giants so they're essentially a
game behind they need to make up a game
over the final four weeks of the season
and since they swept the cowboys and the
cowboys have already beaten the giants
it probably would be useful for
washington for dallas to get
winning and have a three-way tie and
we'd have to go and look at how the tie
breaker would work wouldn't that be
something though a three-way tie where
the three teams involved one swept one
of the others all the way around uh but
uh the the the better path for
washington is just keep winning keep
winning and hope that the giants lose at
some point and maybe it will be
washington hosting that wild card game
the opening weekend of the playoffs at
san francisco next seattle carolina and
philadelphia who's got the easier road
here
oh look whoa i i i'd say it's about a
wash wouldn't you yeah i guess i guess i
maybe would give the advantage
to washington a little bit
uh but it's really close i i yeah i
guess the fact that they get carolina
and philadelphia you know and really the
only one you look at on the giant
schedule there is go okay dallas those
other three teams are pretty damn
quality so i yeah i think the giants
have a little bit of the harder schedule
yeah i do
yeah boy that carolina game extra
meaningful rivera they fired him last
year so uh he no not that not that he
you know doesn't have other reasons to
try to win that game but they'll be a
little bit extra for him
that week uh hey
kudos to the teams of the nfc east i i i
am holding out hope yeah i love chaos i
love events that that will provoke much
needed change and they very much need to
change
this whole concept of being the best of
four bad teams qualifies you for a home
playoff game even if you're below 500
but i'm i'm hoping that between
washington and the giants one of them
will go
three and one down the stretch and
finish eight and eight at least eight
and eight maybe one of them will run the
table and get the nine and seven
wouldn't that be something that would be
something i i i think it's highly
unlikely but uh i think seven and nine
may be more realistic eight and eight
man i just can't see either one of these
teams going three and one against that
schedule they got either one so i expect
a team to be
yeah one of these teams to be seven and
nine below 500 but a pain in the butt to
whoever comes and plays them in the
first round you know as we see it's a
match-up league and the one thing that
the giants and the washington team both
have
is they're big and physical upfront on
both sides of the ball and as we anybody
that's ever paid attention to football
before if you have that then you got a
chance in about against just about
anybody and and that is something
redeemable or at least a quality thing
that the giants and football team have
a much more significant tie on the afc
ledger because whoever wins this one
gets the first week of the playoffs
off the one seed mentioned before that
because the steelers lost to washington
they have the superior conference record
which gives them the tiebreaker edge the
chiefs lost a game in their division
which means they lost a game in their
conference but
down the stretch yeah look the steelers
have
three difficult games out of their final
four
kansas city has
two
so
i you know i i could see this coming
down to week 16 week 17
and uh right now if i had to pick one of
the two teams i think the chiefs are
gonna end up with the one seed how about
you yeah i do too but these two next two
weeks for the chiefs have to play the
miami dolphins and brian flores and that
defense and secondary that's going to be
scary and i don't know if there's a
defense playing better in football than
the saints the next week after that so
there's some work to be done there in
kansas city where i could just you know
where i just don't i don't feel great
about it i think you're right if i had a
bet i'd go with kansas city i would um
the fact that you know the cults
the buffalo bills who we're going to
talk about the next segment the way they
look here as of late i think they're
going to be of course a very tough
matchup for the pittsburgh steelers come
sunday night this week on nbc so that's
going to be a lot of fun um but yeah i
would give the advantage to the chiefs
they're the chiefs they always find a
way to win games that we're not sure if
they are going to win or whatever and
i'm just not going to count them out
when it comes to that
they just have that unintentional flair
where
they they pull it together whether it's
in a game or whether it's in a season
just like last year securing a buy
at the very end of the road right they
just have that way of understanding
timing and making their move at the
right moment and i think they will make
their move and it does help that the
steelers are playing the bills and the
colts and the browns and speaking of the
browns
miles garrett may be getting a little
over his skis here with this one
steelers might have opened the door
double eyeball emoji they might have
opened the door miles but you're two
games behind with four to play
and the steelers have already blown
around
blown them out so let's not let's not
start thinking about maybe winning the
division just be content
with that 97 chance that the browns will
make the playoffs and let's focus miles
on not having that 97 drop to zero
because that would be worse than owen 16
when it's right there
and your hand is beginning to grasp it
and you feel it in your fingers and it
gets ripped away so let's focus on that
not happening concede go ahead and
concede you know we've been waiting for
all sorts of concessions this month yeah
go ahead and concede the afc north to
the steelers because it's just a matter
of time before it happens well they're
not going to do that they're not i mean
and especially with that that schedule
there they're still looking at it like
wait
i mean pittsburgh could lose this week
to buffalo maybe could lose to the colts
right and then there were there we are
cleveland browns and miles garrett
pittsburgh's got to come to cleveland
you got to visit us and if you lose you
could lose the division yeah i think
cleveland after last week probably has a
whole new expectation level with the way
they played at tennessee and the way
they view themselves so um i think they
think they're ready for prime time and
the way that pittsburgh's played the
last two weeks that's probably made them
feel a little bit more comfortable with
that thought
it's funny as i was saying that i'm
thinking this clip is going to be used
against me at some point down the road
potentially so
oh well that's something i can distract
myself with over the next few weeks
here's something you can distract
yourself with on the way to break kudos
to the washington football team's social
media folks for the office
when dwight had the exercise ball that
was driving jim crazy and that becomes
the undefeated season and there go the
steelers and it's just just beautiful
watch closely the nameplate on dwight
schrute's desk says pittsburgh steelers
see that well done washington football
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports